[Music]
welcome back
the little wolf and the black dresses
that's the focus of my bonus angle first
I was remiss on Friday because I did not
mention the part of that Michael Wolf's
Creed that mentioned yours truly
it's just a small antidote that claim
that at the funeral of former Fox News
Chairman Roger Ailes quote right-wing
professionals remain passionate and
their outward defensive trump but were
rattled if not a bastion among one
another at the funeral Rush Limbaugh and
Laura Ingraham struggled to parse
support for Trump ISM easing that even
as they distance themselves from Trump
himself okay I can tell you that that is
totally fabricated it never happened and
by the way it's really poorly written
what does parsing support even mean and
after talking to others who were there I
can tell you that Trump wasn't really
even discussed much if at all at the
funeral but Woolf didn't care he wanted
to advance his rickety anti Trump agenda
the facts be damned
he didn't care and no I didn't buy the
stupid book I borrowed someone else's
all right second the Golden Globes for
once I wasn't in the slightest annoyed
when my cable went out on Sunday night I
have one of those systems they're
supposed to be so great they control all
the TVs it never works I was blissfully
unaware of that hashtag times up in
those black dress declarations by women
who for the most part just happened to
be a bunch of left-wing Democrats same
women who are mostly silent during
Harvey Weinstein's reign of sexual
terror
excuse me but watching a bunch of
self-absorbed actresses try to one-up
each other with emoting and conjured up
empathy isn't exactly my idea of a fun
Sunday night that times up group led by
left-wing
industry types announced before the show
that they'd all be wearing black to
protest men who harass women there
wasn't much of a mention of women who
harassed men as I recall imagine the
pressure on
young actresses in attendance to conform
not only are so many in the industry
afraid to express views that may be
remotely conservative now they're afraid
to dress the way they want a dress and
the color they want aware so how is it
any less demeaning and domineering for a
bunch of powerful women to tell other
women what to wear than it is for
powerful men to do the same answer it's
not and that's for resulting in some
tangible change for the farm workers and
the hospitality workers well I'll let
Rose McGowan the actress largely
responsible for blowing the whistle on
the sleaze in Hollywood sum it up she
said that's a band-aid to make yourself
feel better about what you've all known
about and been silent witnesses with
witnesses to and/or participants in that
silence and no I don't forgive well now
Washington is taking up that tedious
torch of fake protest a group of
Democratic lawmakers have announced that
they're going to be wearing wait for it
black in supportive times up in that
movement at the State of the Union
another reason not to watch a foreign
for President Trump I wouldn't must
every moment of our communal life be
overshadowed by protest and then there's
Oprah Winfrey now I caught her speech on
YouTube I had a five hour delay coming
back from the big game last night it was
nicely written and it was well delivered
her talk at the Golden Globes but it was
also purely political are we to believe
that she liked Meryl Streep and on all
the other actresses producers and so
forth just had their epiphanies about
Weinstein Spacey and all the rest of
them in Hollywood Oprah who by the way
has spoke really compellingly about the
abuse she suffered as a child she had
the biggest megaphone in the media for
decades surely she knew that both
straight and gay men in Hollywood had
abused their positions of power for
years there are victims all over the
place so my question is what took them
so long here's my angle on this
since that Russia collusion narrative
about President Trump hasn't
materialized and since all these
predictions about the Trump pocalypse
haven't come true the economy is doing
so well the left is desperately
scrambling for anything to hold on to
anything to give them hope
so it's hoprah she's their lifeline well
I say Oprah should throw her head in the
ring why not the president apparently
feels the same Oprah would be a lot of
fun I know her very well you know I did
one of her last shows she had Donald
Trump is before politics for last week
and she had Donald Trump and my family
was very nice no I like Oprah I don't
think she's gonna run
look Oprah's accomplished she's fun to
watch she's smart and I think she'll
also quickly see just how different
politics is from hosting a talk show
different game America isn't the room
who gave her the standing Oh on Sunday
night and if she did run before long I
predict she's gonna have a lot more
respect for just how hard it was for
Donald Trump a total outsider to
politics to have run beating all those
Republicans beat the Obamas beat the
Clintons beat the media beat Hollywood
and win it all
Oprah Winfrey versus who who could she
run against she could run against Matt
Damon George Clooney Rosie Elizabeth
Warren what other parade of horrible can
I trot out